Hello. My name is,
Natasha Varitimou,
and I'm a data
architect in UBS.
More specifically,
I'm the modeler in the UBS
knowledge graph.
So, we will discuss today what
were the issues
and requirements
that we had in UBS
and how the UBS
knowledge graph facilitated
the way that we
deal with these
requirements. So,
every organization in order to
increase its revenue
has two ways.
One way is to increase its
customer base,
which is something
that every organization
is trying to do,
but you cannot
do it multi fold
over time.
The second way is to
decrease its debt.
So the question that we had in
UBS is how do I
decrease my debt,
and more specifically,
how do I reduce my
debt in the IT world,
in the technical landscape?
So in order to do that,
we had to answer
some questions.
What are my applications in my
IT landscape?
What is the software
and hardware
they leverage?
How much does
an application cost me?
How can I reduce this cost?
Do I invest too much money in
applications that I should be
decommissioning?
There are a lot
of questions where the answers
were not that
straightforward.
It wasn't easy.
It wasn't we couldn't
give answers
immediately. They were it was
very time consuming
to actually
search for the data that will
actually help me facilitate me
to answer these questions.
That is because
our IT landscape,
the view for our IT landscape
wasn't very clear.
The data that would help us
answer these questions were
hidden between
behind different
applications, so
they were hidden
in sign laws.
They were named differently.
We had many
duplicated information
from application
to application,
and, of course, we
had redundancies.
And, all these questions,
these challenges were
not only we don't,
face them only in UBS.
I have seen this
is actually a data
definition and data
integration problem,
and I have seen it in many
organizations and
independent the size.
I've seen it in many sectors.
I have worked in
governmental,
projects, in my
previous roles,
governmental projects
in Brussels.
I have worked in oil and gas
projects in Norway.
I have worked for
life sciences
and pharma. I've worked for
consumer goods.
The latest years,
I have been focusing
in the financial
sector, but as I said,
independent the sector,
independent the size,
independent the project,
the challenges were
always the same.
The data questions
were always the same.
So the solution,
in a few words,
is federated and model driven
layered architecture,
and this is what I'm going to
present to you today,
how we solved how we created
this in UBS.
So So I'm gonna structure
the presentation
by breaking down the data
challenges one by
one and giving
and presenting
the solution that
we actually gave for
each challenge.
So the first question,
and it seems very simple,
while it is not is
what is my data?
We need
a consistent description
and representation
of the data.
Sometimes the the same real
world concept in
the same organization,
but in different parts
of the organization
or maybe in the same part of
the organization
between different
teams, the the same real world
concepts are called
differently.
So some people might call
something a system,
for example,
and then other
teams might call
it infrastructure,
and other teams
might call it,
hardware. So we
don't know that
we indeed, we are
talking about
the same thing.
We need common terms
to the organization
. We need descriptions
for these
common terms, and we need to
know what is the what
are the relations
between them.
So what we actually
need is a model.
This is what a model brings to
the table.
So we need
an enterprise agreed
model so everybody would refer
to the same real
world concepts
the same way, and we need to
document it in a model.
Now, if this model
is a UML model,
is a model documented
in a picture,
in a conference page,
in a document anywhere,
then people could
understand and
see this model and maybe see
the descriptions as well in
the relations, but machines
cannot understand it.
So machines cannot
answer the same
questions that people can.
So in a question,
a person could go and search
based on this model,
but the machine cannot
a software agent,
an application cannot
search for this,
based on this model.
So we need machine
readable models.
So the same way
that a person,
a human can understand it,
a machine or
an application can
understand it as well.
And we also need the data to
live together with
these machine
readable models.
This is what Tim Berners Lee
called knowledge graph.
Machine readable
models and data
living together
so everybody can
search for the information
they need,
not only, as I said, humans,
but also applications
and software
agents can navigate through
these models, get
the data they want,
can discover new information,
follow their nose, and,
do more complex queries.
Right. Some
organizations have,
reached this level
of maturity,
but, at least to
have an enterprise
agreed model, but
just a few and
probably, UBS is
the first that
is doing it in such
a large scale.
We are doing it
actually we have
a a knowledge graph
in the middle
of our architecture as you see
here in our in this, diagram.
So in the middle of this pink
part is actually our models,
which are we call them
upper ontologies,
which are normalized,
consistent,
clear descriptions
of our data.
Actually, we have gone
one step further.
So they are not
just ontologies.
They are Shackle models,
which is Shackle is a a state
of the art,
modeling language
where you not
only describe in a machine
readable way your model,
but you actually can use this
model to validate
the data against
this model and report some
inconsistencies, if any.
So in this middle layer in our
knowledge graph,
we have our upper
anthologies,
and we have our data living
together consistently.
In our upper ontologies,
in our upper shackle models,
we are trying to
utilize as many
standards as we
can so we will,
we don't have to
reinvent the wheel,
and we'll also,
succeed interoperability.
So we are utilizing
we are using
as much as we can
Dublin Core.
We're using consents
from Fibo.
We are using, Prov
for provenance.
We are using TCAT to
describe datasets.
We are using DataCube and SDMX
to describe
statistics, metrics,
and dimensions.
We are trying to reuse as many
standards, especially w three
c standards, as we can.
As I said in the beginning,
we began by trying to describe
our technical landscape,
so we needed
a technical ontology.
However, this was,
surprising,
I would say. We couldn't find
something to reuse.
There wasn't
a standard technical
ontology out there
that we could
just reuse and extend
if necessary.
I see surprising because every
organization has
an IT department.
I I suppose that
every organization
wanted to wants
to describe its
applications, its
how hardware,
its software,
all the cloud
capabilities they have,
how they are all
tied together.
However, as I said,
we couldn't find any,
so we created our
own ontology.
So that is our model layer in
our architecture.
But then the second challenge
is how do I bring
my data in and
describe it with
these models?
Where is my data?
Where is this data
coming from?
How do I track
their provenance?
How do I track how
the data flow,
in order for me to
have a lineage,
aspect on my universe?
For example,
if I change something
in my data,
what does it affect
downstream?
Or if I have
a change somewhere,
what does, if I
have something,
how do is it affected from any
chains they do upstream?
This is what we call lineage.
So this is a second this was
the second challenge.
So the the solution
to this one
is federated architecture.
We don't have we we utilize
microservices to
actually bring
the data in from
its data sources.
The data sources
themselves are
also described
very clearly with
taxonomies. We have people and
roles around these
microservices,
so we have a well documented,
ecosystem of each
data that are
coming from this
microservice.
Again, for
the microservices and
for our publishing,
we didn't create
a wrong technology.
We didn't use
a proprietary technology.
There was again,
we didn't reinvent the wheel
because there was there were
technologies out there,
very well known
ones, tried ones,
and guaranteed.
It was the HTTP protocol that
is used in the web.
It was the URI's
URI techniques.
It was, as I said,
vocabularies like d cat where
we will describe the datasets
as they were coming,
as you see here,
from the different publishing
microservices to our
knowledge graph.
And, of course,
we we also utilize Prove.
So every time
a bunch of data,
what we call dataset,
is coming in
the knowledge graph,
we always track and
we see an example
here. We always
track what this
dataset is, what
are the persons,
and what are the roles around
this dataset, and we always
track where they
are coming from.
So a dataset might
be generated
by an ingest activity coming
from an original source,
from an application,
but it could also be generated
by a transform
activity derived,
as you see here
in the example,
from two other datasets.
These datasets,
in their term,
are generated by a transfer or
by an ingest activity.
That way, we,
track the lineage of our data
with datasets
being first class
citizens.
Third challenge,
I have now a very
good architecture.
I have my data very
well published,
described, consistent, and,
with usability and,
guaranteed data quality.
How do not, how can I
now use this data?
Different teams have different
needs on the data.
For example, there might be,
one part of the organization,
one team that would,
need just a specific glance,
a specific lens
on the data and
not see the whole universe,
a knowledge graph can be,
intimidating sometimes because
it has a lot of information.
So someone would just want to
see just a lightweight,
simple,
view of the data.
There might be
other teams that
want some of the data,
so cherry pick
some of the data,
and they want it in
specific formats,
other teams in other formats.
So how do I cover
all these cases?
We have different ways to deal
with these challenges,
so our ways vary for
facilitating different,
extension lighter
models or our on our,
bigger, fuller knowledge graph
to having,
different types facilitating
different types of queries and
rest APIs.
So in our architecture,
this is described
here in the upper
layer. So as you see,
although this middle layer,
our knowledge graph creates
the integration platform,
we can have multiple ways to
interact with it.
That will vary.
We have a a very nice UI,
so it's like a a web browser
search on our
knowledge graph.
So someone could just,
put a term in it.
And a lot of links
appear where
you can follow your nose and
discover more information just
like you would do,
in a search engine.
We have a a Quibi interface,
a sparkle endpoint,
so someone could write very,
more complicated queries.
And when you save them,
they are immediately
saved as REST APIs,
so they could be,
invoked from any
other application
or invoked from any user in
the UI and see
the results in the UI.
We have, what we call guided
search where it is
again a web browser,
just all the other browsers,
but you can,
you can cherry pick
specific properties,
specific information
on your on
your concepts, to see.
So, actually, under the hood,
that creates a sparkle query,
but it this is
under the hood,
and guided search provide to
users that are not
familiar with SPARQL.
Most of the users
are not familiar
with SPARQL, an intuitive way
of creating complex queries in
the knowledge graph.
We always we also
have, of course,
free text search,
which will make
more efficient,
based on elastic search,
and we are going to
create a faceted
search. So someone
could search
and filter based on specific
properties on the concepts.
This is the more,
direct way to interact
with a knowledge
graph. Sorry. Go back.
But, there will we also have
other teams that they interact
with a knowledge graph,
with a consistent integrated
middle layer that
we see here.
They interact in their own way
based on different
the different
ways that I said before.
But, also, there is a way,
and I think that
in the future,
it would be more obvious as we
bring more data
in the knowledge
graph and we have
more use cases.
There will be
the need of lighter,
extended models,
as we call them,
where the data are
also described
with these lighter models,
and we need to
transform the data
from the fuller, more,
heavyweight knowledge graph to
these lighter small pods.
Of course, the trick here is,
always be synchronized
and consistent.
That is the trick.
And, otherwise,
you can interact in
many simpler ways,
but the with
the middle integration
layer.
There are also,
though, times,
and this is the last
challenge,
that, you cannot
bring your data
in the knowledge graph.
This might be for
time or priority
or resources restrictions,
but it is not,
always possible immediately to
publish the data in
the knowledge graph.
In this case, if I cannot
integrate the actual data,
what I do is I can integrate
the metadata and that is what
we call dataset registry.
So dataset registry,
I have seen it with different
terms in different companies.
Other companies
call it metadata
repositories,
metadata registries,
dataset catalog,
data dictionaries.
What they all mean and what we
actually do in our dataset
registry is in
order to achieve,
again, the integration and
facilitate
integrated information
across our data
sources when we
cannot bring
the data itself in
the knowledge graph,
we are bringing
the description
of our datasets.
So we are not
bringing the datasets
in the Knowledge Graph,
We are bringing
their descriptions
saying that this
is the physical
structure. A dataset actually
although you don't
see for example,
if it is a tabular dataset,
maybe we don't see its rows,
but I'm going to describe and
say that this dataset
has, actually,
these tables and
these columns in it,
and I we map these
tables and columns,
these physical
structures, again,
to the enterprise
agreed logical model.
That way,
you can query over
your universe
if you manage to map
it to the logical
model. You can
query your universe
just as if data were in your
knowledge graph.
However, in this case,
just because you
don't have the data,
you will need
a resolution service
here to say, what is
it that you want?
Do you want applications in
software and hardware?
These datasets have them in.
We can see it
from its physical
structure, and this is how you
can get it. But you will need
now the resolution
service based
on these instructions
to actually
go and get the data.
So our architecture
in our dataset
registry is actually
to describe
the datasets again,
their physical structures,
the way they map
to the logical
enterprise agreed
model, and, that way,
you can actually
get the information
again that you need.
Just want to emphasize again
here that dataset registry is
a very nice first step to
integrate your universe,
but it is just
the first step.
It just just a small part of
your entire knowledge graph.
And the biggest benefits,
the greatest arch
data architecture
that you can have is when your
data is in your universe.
But as I said,
sometimes you have
to do things,
step by step, and the dataset
registry is, for certain,
a very well way to start,
getting to integrate your,
data landscape.
So, we are actively working on
our dataset registry,
which is the catalog
of catalogs.
We are bringing
we will we will
bring all datasets in,
and we are going to
have an explorer
where someone could
go and search
the datasets, see
its usability,
and structures, in
the same way that,
our explorer would be the same
way that Google had,
its dataset explorer.
We are also using d cat,
to describe our datasets,
but we extend it,
as we're saying,
to describe their physical
structures and
their mappings.
I think that is,
what I wanted to
share today, and,
hope, I gave you
an overview of
the federated and model driven
layered architecture
that we are
establishing in UBS.
And, looking forward,
for stimulating discussions in
the context of
the conference.
Thank you very much,
and, thank you.